[Music]
all right let's take one more let's go
to jace in
columbia missouri what's up jace
hey how are you doing remarkable brother
how are you i'm doing great cool so
what's up dude
so
um i am the general manager of a 40 year
old family carpet cleaning business
um i'm third generation and it's what i
wanted to do my entire life as long as i
can remember it's so cool man awesome
yeah uh i've been back as the general
manager for the last i guess four years
in january
and i'm going through a season where it
feels like everyone is leaving
oh yeah
yeah
one guy i was pretty close with um a
couple weeks ago left with two days
notice um why
uh
he said it was money
um that worked kind of seasonal but it's
been something that i've been working on
since i've been back um didn't give me a
lot of explanation but when he told me i
was more in shock mode than i was to
like try and dissect it
um
yeah
and then
uh
um no one's he's the only one that's
left so far there's another one that has
told
intends to leave in the next month or so
by once again citing uh money or more
consistent hours that kind of stuff yeah
um and then i've heard
rumors and rumors um from
one of the guys that's been with us for
26 years um
about some of the other guys that have
been talking about
not being around in the in the next like
couple quarters probably
so in a family business
something you've wanted to do your whole
life
this feels real personal doesn't it
yeah they're not quitting a job for a
dollar an hour they're leaving
like they're leaving you
yeah there's been some of that yeah i
wanna i wanna tell you
i'm glad this is keeping you up that
means you're a good leader
that means your heart's in the right
place so good for you
it's good if you were like well screw
you i'll go then i would
tell you you probably shouldn't be
leading people so the fact that this is
sitting in your soul and it hurts a
little bit that's good i'm glad that's
happening okay i'm not i'm not happy for
your discomfort but i'm glad that that's
your disposition you care about this
thing
and so
a couple of things i want you to think
about
one is
facts are your friends are they right
and anytime somebody says i'm i don't
want to be around you because you're a
jerk or whenever we have team meetings
and james says
when you are late john
here's how this affects everybody else
uh first thing i have to ask is is he
right
and he is he's right and so when you
hear people saying about money this and
money that what
ques are they right
have they gotten disconnected from the
family mission which is
we are helping people
we're not just cleaning carpets we are
taking care of people have you taken
this guy that that you were close to
that just quit on two days notice
there's something else going on there
because friends i mean connected people
don't do that to each other
and so
have you taken him out for coffee just
or grab a beer and be like all right so
you're gone cool we're cool
tell me like what really is going on
because that's not something people do
even jerks give two weeks notice you
know what i mean
so i'll ask you what what are the facts
here are do they have a point is what
they're saying true
um
i don't yeah i don't know i haven't
talked to him much since since he left
and that's probably a misstep on me i
just
i don't know i had yeah it's new it's
grief i mean
make the next right step right i mean
don't don't go backwards just make the
next right step yeah
um but you know
i think a lot of the guys that work for
us and being service
industry they
to see the world through a very short
term wins so we are very seasonal um so
we're working a lot of our work is in
the summer time so they're working i
mean some of them are working 60 hours a
week for a short period of time
and like that's where
uh you make your money but when they
spend that all throughout the rest of
the year
then it gets real tight this time of
year when i can basically guarantee them
30 to 35 hours a week gotcha gotcha yeah
so
as a leader
it's really easy to
look at them and blame them for how they
handle their money or for not planning
right or there's too short term or
whatever what i would love to see you do
is to offer solutions and opportunities
for them
one of those may be
a i want to call a staff like an all
team meeting we're going to have dinner
and we're going to talk through some
things i'm gonna give y'all an
opportunity to be heard
like what's going on in your hearts and
minds we've had a crazy 24 months
i may be missing something you know
maybe like walk me through what your
life has been like
give them an opportunity to fill out
like a questionnaire or to raise their
hands and just listen and you can tell
i'm not going to say anything i'm just
going to listen tonight and i'm going to
pay for dinner i'm going to pay y'all
for the two hours you're here
like tell me what's going on in your
world and then from that conversation
you might get
um
here is like if you work 60 hours these
four months and you work 35 hours these
other eight months your total at the end
of the year is 45 000
here's how we can here's like ramsay's
the company i work for has a a money
tool for businesses just like that they
just help people over the arc of a year
in their with their smart dollar product
right it's an hr product
is there a product you can help with or
is there a i'm gonna teach budgeting
classes on the weekend or i'm going to
also create another does anybody have
another idea for a business in the off
months and listen to those customers
i'll pay a thousand dollars
in cash for the person who comes up with
the
uh the new opportunity for the
off-season is that you but you're
bringing them along and suddenly they've
got purpose they're a part of this thing
they're not just carpet cleaners
yeah and for you this is a family
business this is third generation i've
always wanted to do this thing
you've got to understand they don't have
that investment right now and i'll blame
you the leader you got to give them that
investment
so then so the other wrinkle being i
mean i'm just
for lack of a better work term word or
whatever um just more so middle
management so i got my my dad and uncle
are co-owners and they're the operations
there
and
i feel like i'm in a sometimes in a
cycle of
like asking for kind of a vision and a
leadership and er not leadership but
just a vision of like where we're going
or like when is the transition like how
what does that look like all that kind
of stuff
and
it leads to frustration and then i mean
obviously i bring that home yeah home
life and all that kind of stuff so that
when you ask for those questions they
just want to answer you or they say i'll
talk about it later
it's one of those things it's like
yeah it's not the most pressing issue
how much do you make a year me
what's your take home
my
take home is this you're going to be 75
okay
here's what i want you to do and this is
going to sound bonkers
okay
i want you just to for the first time
maybe in your life
i want you to survey your area where you
live
and see how many jobs are between 60 and
80 000
for a gem of a successful carpet company
cleaning company
is there other service oriented jobs
and here's why i'm telling you that
your family is not worth this
your heart and soul is not worth this
and if you've got two family member
owners who won't tell you what the
future is going to look like won't catch
the vision and won't let you do that
what i'm going to tell you is you're
going to end up bitter and exhausted and
chasing people and you're going to end
up cleaning the carpet at 2 a.m because
you got no workers
and you're gonna have no say on anything
and your family isn't worth that and you
are worth more than that
and i'm not telling you to leave i'm
telling you right now you're starting to
i can hear it in you you're starting to
feel trapped
and when we get trapped we make dumb
decisions
yeah we do
that's when we respond to that girl's
text
that's when we have one too many drinks
and we get in a car or we just do stupid
stuff that's when we yell at our wife or
our kids and we didn't mean to that's we
just do dumb we go buy a car that we
don't need
we just do dumb stuff am i on the right
track
yeah no that makes sense i haven't
thankfully haven't gotten to that point
where i've done dumb stuff but i feel
like i've been in this cycle of you're
on the road i'm trapped but
every six months or so i sit down with
my dad it's like that bent up
frustrations and yes we handle things
when they're at an eight or nine rather
than dealing with things when you're at
a one or two
nat dude the fact that you have that
language is incredible
so the goal now is this i want you to
have
i want you just to survey the area and
not feel trapped you might look around
and be like dude the highest paying job
is 41 000 and that's it like i'm kind of
in this job
my guess is with your experience and
your character
and your drive there's going to be some
opportunities for you especially now
right now especially in the service
sector
i want you to get look around
and i know this has been your lifelong
dream and it may be your lifelong career
and it may not
so i want you to at least go look
and when you have some
huh there's an opportunity over there
that might be kind of awesome and
they're going to give me full reign and
i'm going to make 140 000 a year i'm
gonna have to work like crazy
but i'll get to make some leadership
decisions i'll get to honor some of
these people i'll get to have
conversations about dollars per hour and
whatever
my life would be better that's when you
sit down with your
old man and you say
here's how this is about to go i'm gonna
leave or this and then he gets to make
grown-up boundary decisions
but right now he's acting like a child
and he's treating you like he's
like you still live in his house
like you're a child and you're not
you're a grown man
with your own family
and
i still think you
get all of your people together you pay
him for two hours and you serve him
dinner and you say
i just want to take a state of the union
how is everybody
and as a general manager you're allowed
to do that
and if your father or
uncle say you're not
you're not having dinner with those that
that crew they're just the workers then
you quit
you go find another job because that
tells you all you need to know there's
no way they're gonna do that
but i think you should then listen to
your team
and you begin to paint a vision of
y'all we're not just cleaning carpets
we're helping families
we're helping people save their home
we are helping fill in the blank we're
taking care of people we have a purpose
and y'all are a part of that purpose and
by the way anybody comes up with the
off-season business
cash i'll give you cash
and now man people aren't gonna leave on
two days notice i want you to take that
guy out though also take that guy out
for coffee and just be like all right
brother go grab a beer and say
where are we at man where are we at
what happened
what happened how can i be better
thanks for the call jace you're awesome
brother